[Musik]
ein Land trauert seit gestern Abend
immer weiter strömen Menschen zum
Buckingham Palast um sich von ihrer
Queen zu verabschieden
alle Zeitungen Ehren Elisabeth II und im
Unterhaus erheben sich die Abgeordneten
zur Schweigeminute
schon am Nachmittag hatte sich Charles
vor dem Palast für so viel Anteilnahme
bedankt 70 Jahre lang Thronfolger ab
jetzt Charles III der neue König
und in wenigen Minuten will sich der
neue König ans Volk wenden wir schauen
auf die Rede und damit herzlich
willkommen zu den Nachrichten ja und
auch der britische Sport Norbert
verneigt sich ja vor der Queen alle
Fußballspiele der Premier League wurden
fürs Wochenende abgesagt und doch viele
andere Sportveranstaltungen auf der
Insel ja weltweit wird der Queen gedacht
10 Tage lang wird jetzt zum Vereinigten
Königreich offiziell getrauert erinnern
werden sich die Menschen an Elisabeth II
aber noch lange sie war die am längsten
regierende britische Monarchin bis die
Königin im Alter von 96 Jahren starb
gestern Abend wurde am Buckingham Palast
in London der Welt offiziell der Tod der
Queen mitgeteilt
Bedienstete Royals brachten die
Bekanntmachung am Zaun an
der plötzliche Tod ist ein Schock für
Großbritannien sieben jahrzehntelang war
Elisabeth die zweite Königin viele haben
nur sie auf dem Thron gekannt während
ihrer Regentschaft erlebte Elisabeth 15
premierministerinnen und Premierminister
von Winston Churchill bis jetzt List
Trust Haltung Pflichterfüllung eine
moralische Instanz in sich ändernden
Zeiten das war die Queen für die
allermeisten Menschen in ihrem
Königreich lückweipert
Punkt 13 Uhr halt Kanonen Donner durch
London die Nation erinnert mit 96
Salutschüssen an die Verstorbene Königin
in London und Schottland Nordirland oder
Gibraltar den ganzen Tag überströmten
Trauernde Briten zum Buckingham Palast
mit Blumen und Kondolenzschreiben tief
bewegt und voller Dankbarkeit für
Elisabeth II
ich war am Boden zerstörtes lässt sich
gar nicht in Worte fassen
in meinem Leben über 40 Jahre lang das
wird ein tiefer Einschnitt
ich bin kein großer Anhänger der
Monarchie aber diese Frau war ein
unglaubliches Symbol weltweit eine
bewundernswerte Frau die ihren Job
unglaublich gut gemacht hat
auf ihn richten sich jetzt die Blicke
Charles verließ am Mittag Schloss
baumorl wo die verstaubte Monarchien
aufgebahrt wurde er flog zurück nach
London am Buckingham Palast wurde er mit
seiner Frau Camilla von Jubel den
Bürgern begrüßt mit Begeisterung
schüttelten sie die Hände des neuen
Königs eine ungewohnte Rolle für den
Mann der sechs jahrzehntelang als Prinz
von Wales im Schatten seiner Mutter
stand anschließend traf er zu einem
ersten politischen Austausch mit der
neuen Premierministerin Liz Trust
zusammen schon am Morgen hatten die
Abgeordneten bei einer Gedenkstunde im
Unterhaus dem Verstorbenen
Staatsoberhaupt ihren tiefen Respekt
bezeugt
unsere Verstorbenen Majestät ist ein
Sinnbild für alles wofür Großbritannien
als Nation steht es prägt Münzen
Briefmarken Porträts weltweit ihr
Vermächtnis wird allen die sie getroffen
haben in Erinnerung bleiben
wir sollten uns immer an das großartige
der Herrschaft dieser Königin erinnern
dass wir immer besser sind wenn wir das
alltägliche kleinkarierte hinter uns
lassen und uns auf das besinnen was
wirklich zählt das was uns eint nicht
das was uns trennt
kein leichtes Erbe für den neuen König
der Briten
und der Leichnam der Königin ist noch in
Schottland vom Schloss bei Moral wird am
Sonntag nach Edinburgh überführt und
dort in Schottland ist für uns Diana
Zimmermann diana ist ja wirklich
minoziös festgelegt was bis zum
Staatsbegräbnis passiert was sieht denn
das Protokoll für die nächsten Tage vor
ja wie du schon gesagt hast am Sonntag
kommt sie nach Edinburgh die Tatsache
dass die Queen ausgerechnet auf ihrem
Lieblingsschloss belmael gestorben ist
führt dazu dass von den zwölf Tagen
Trauer 5 in Schottland stattfinden das
ist für die Schotten natürlich ein
Geschenk am Dienstag wird sie dann von
Schottland nach London gebracht dort
wird sie auch noch mal aufgebaut und die
Londoner und die angereisten Briten
können dort von ihr Abschied nehmen und
am Montag in einer Woche findet dann das
große Begräbnis statt morgen wird King
Charles zum König programmiert offiziell
was er schon ist und er begibt sich dann
auf eine Reise durch alle Nationen um
klar zu machen dass das Königreich eben
aus vier Nationen besteht Dankeschön
Diana zimmermann
ja die britische Königin war auch
international hochgeachtet über die
Jahrzehnte traf Elisabeth II mit vielen
Persönlichkeiten aus der ganzen Welt
zusammen jede dieser Begegnungen war
historisch setzte Zeichen der
Verbundenheit oder aber der Hoffnung auf
die Zukunft die internationalen Reaktion
auf den Tod der Queen hat Franziska von
thesenhausen
Australien trauert um Elizabeth II 70
Jahre lang war sie auch hier
Staatsoberhaupt viele können es noch
nicht fassen
ihre Majestät hat unserem und vielen
anderen Ländern so lange gedient dass
sie ein Teil unseres Lebens geworden ist
wir sind geschockt jetzt wird alles
anders sein
mehr als zwei Milliarden Menschen
weltweit sind durch das Commonwealth auf
besondere Weise mit dem britischen
Königshaus verbunden auch in Kanada
nehmen sie Abschied von ihrer Königin
es fällt mir schwer zu fassen dass mein
letztes Treffen mit ihr das letzte war
ich werde unsere Gespräche sehr
vermissen
und auch in Hongkong das mehr als 150
Jahre unter britischer Herrschaft stand
gedenken viele heute der Queen
ich vermisse sie sehr und ich bin ihr
dankbar für die vielen Jahre die sie
Hongkong regiert hat
Sir Elton John der eng mit dem
Königshaus verbunden ist erfuhr auf
Tournee vom Tod der Queen
ich bin 75 und sie war immer Teil meines
Lebens ich bin sehr traurig dass sie
nicht mehr da ist aber ihre Seele lebt
weiter und heute feiern wir ihr Leben
mit Musik
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die Queen und Deutschland das war ein
ganz besonderes Verhältnis vor allem
weil sie so viel für die Aussöhnung der
einzigen Kriegsgegner getan hat
1965 der erste von fünf Staatsbesuchen
und gleichzeitig der erste Besuch eines
britischen Staatsoberhaupts in
Deutschland nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
1992 bei ihrem dritten Besuch kurz nach
der Wiedervereinigung betritt die Queen
erstmals auch ostdeutschen Boden und
zuletzt war Queen Elizabeth II 2015 bei
uns Andrea Maurer mit den deutschen
Reaktionen
viele Menschen kommen heute zur
britischen Botschaft um Blumen
niederzulegen die Queen verbindet auch
in Deutschland Generationen eine Königin
der Herzen in der deutschen
nachkriegsdemokratie wird sehr dazu
beigetragen dass Deutschland auch nach
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg und all dem
grauenhaften wieder einen Platz in der
Weltgeschichte und in der weltweiten
Gemeinschaft bekommen hat auch gleich
nach dem Mauerfall also ja ich glaube
sie macht uns gerne natürlich
können wir froh und dankbar sein wenn
Menschen und so die Hand reichen
nach unserer Geschichte
1965 betritt die Queen zum ersten Mal
deutschen Boden 20 Jahre nach dem Ende
der Naziherrschaft eine Geste der
Versöhnung insgesamt fünf Mal besucht
sie Deutschland wie wertvoll der Frieden
in Europa ist hat sie immer betont
Bundestagspräsidentin Bars eröffnet die
Parlamentssitzung heute im Gedenken an
die Monarchin bei ihrem Staatsbesuch
2015 der ihr letzter Staatsbesuch
überhaupt bleiben sollte bezeichnete sie
die Beziehung zwischen unseren Ländern
als eine der unumkehrbaren Veränderungen
zum besseren in ihrer Lebenszeit es ging
ihr wie sie es ausdrückte um eine
vollständige Aussöhnung auch der Kanzler
würdigt die Königin heute als
jahrhundertfigur die Queen verkörperte
das beste unseres gemeinsamen
europäischen Erbes Demokratie und
Rechtsstaatlichkeit
Königin Elisabeth II sie wird auch
Deutschland und vielen deutschen viel
als ältester Sohn der Queen ist die
Krone automatisch an Charles
übergegangen mit Spannung wurde an
diesem Abend seine Rede an die Nation
als neuer König erwartet welche Worte
findet er seine Ansprache im britischen
Fernsehen hat gerade begonnen hören wir
rein
ich spreche heute zu ihnen mit Gefühlen
einer tiefen Trauer in ihrem ganzen
Leben hat die ihrem Majestät die Königin
meine liebe Mutter mir und der ganzen
Familie als Inspiration
gedient und wir
schulden dir großen Dank
für ihre Liebe ihre Zuneigung ihre
Anleitung ihr gutes Beispiel
Königin Elisabeth das war ein Leben das
gut gelebt war und das Versprechen des
Schicksals wurde gehalten und sie wird
sehr tief bedauert
dieses Versprechen des lebenslangen
Dienstes erneuere ich heute an alle
neben der persönlichen Trauer meiner
Familie teilen wir mit so vielen von
ihnen
Großbritannien in allen Ländern wo die
Königin Stars überhaupt war im
Commonwealth und auf der ganzen Welt
einen tiefen Sinn für Dankbarkeit für
diese mehr als 70 Jahren in denen meine
Mutter als Königin den Menschen von so
vielen Nationen gedient hat
1947 als sie 21 wurde
versprach sie in einer Sendung aus
Kapstadt dem Commonwealth ihr Leben
hinzugeben ob es lang oder kurz sei für
den Dienst an ihren Völkern
und das war mehr als ein Versprechen es
war eine tiefe
persönlich Verpflichtung die ihr ganzes
Leben definiert dass sie hat Opfer auf
sich genommen für ihre Pflicht
ihre Hingabe
als Monarchin
waren die geschwächt in Zeiten der
Veränderungen des Fortschritts in Zeiten
der Freude und der feiern und in Zeiten
der Traurigkeit und des Verlustes in dem
ihrem Leben
des Dienstes
hat sie die Tradition eingehalten und
gleichzeitig sich dem Fortschritt
verpflichtet gefühlt und das macht uns
sehr groß als Nation die Zuneigung
Bewunderung und der Respekt
der ihr entgegengebracht wurden waren
das Kennzeichen ihrer Regentschaft und
jedes Mitglied meiner Familie kann
bezeugen dass sie diese Qualitäten mit
Wärme Humor
und einer immer klaren Fähigkeit
verbannt das Beste in den Menschen zu
sehen ich würdige das Andenken meiner
Mutter und ich ehre ihr Leben des
Dienstes
ich weiß dass ihr das war so der Anfang
der ersten Rede des neuen Königs Andreas
Stamm in London hat das für uns verfolgt
Andreas wie haben sie den Auftritt von
König Scheitz erlebt
ja das war natürlich eine definierende
Rede das darf man nicht vergessen die
Queen hat in 70 Jahren 5 solcher
Ansprachen an die Nationen gehalten das
war eine von Prinz Charles König Charles
und er hat drei Dinge glaube ich
klargemacht erstens es war ein
unheimlich warmherziger emotionaler
Tribut an seine Mutter ich glaube da hat
er den den Zeitgeist hier Begriffen es
geht im Moment nicht um ihn noch nicht
sondern um das Ableben seiner Mutter
zweitens es geht um Kontinuität er hat
eines der zentralen versprechen
wiederholt nämlich zu dienen dem Land
dem Vereinigten Königreich das was seine
Mutter 1947 gemacht hat das hat er
wiederholt und damit will er Kontinuität
anstreben genauso wie er auch erklärt
hat dass er unparteiischer sein wird
denn er war ja oft in der Kritik dass er
sich zu sehr in politische Dinge
eingemischt hat und das wird jetzt auch
nicht mehr so sein das hat er
erklärt und das dritte glaube ich ist
dann auch dass er sich ein bisschen als
übergangskönig sieht hat Prinz William
Catherine seine Frau erwähnt für die
bereitet er jetzt das Feld und der weiße
hat nur noch
nicht mehr so viele Jahre das hat er
auch anklingen lassen also er sieht sich
vielleicht ein wenig als übergangskönig
und hat er darüber hinaus noch eine
besondere Botschaft an die Nation
ich glaube die wirklich entscheidende
Botschaft hier war der Tribut an seine
Mutter das ist auch das was hier die
Tage bestimmt hatte diese 70 Jahre Queen
Elizabeth II das ist der prägende
Eindruck noch an diesen ersten Tag nach
ihrem Tod das überstrahlt alles und
dieser barmherzige Tribut dass er in
ihre Fußstapfen gehen will weiß aber
dass er die wahrscheinlich nie erreichen
kann ich glaube das war die zentrale
Botschaft aber er wird alles daran
setzen Kontinuität zu wahren und eben
dieser übergangskönig vielleicht zu
werden danke für diese Einschätzung aus
London Andreas
und die gesamte Rede können Sie im
Anschluss an diese Sendungen in einem
heute Spezial sehen außerdem halten wir
Sie in unserer ZDF heute App auf dem
Laufenden
blicken wir jetzt auf die weiteren
Themen dieses Tages wie geht man mit den
steigenden Energiepreisen um der
gastversorger VNG hat heute Hilfe vom
deutschen Staat beantragt da die
ausbleibenden russischen Gaslieferungen
nun teuer aus anderen Quellen ersetzt
werden müssten VNG ist die Nummer 3 auf
dem deutschen Markt die Hilfe werden wir
auch hinbekommen sagte dazu
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck am Rande
eines sondertreffens der für
energiezuständigen eu-ministerin und
Minister in Brüssel auch da das Thema
die Energiekrise Isabell Schäfers eine
Minute Stille in Gedenken an die Queen
doch dann ist das Innehalten vorbei die
eu-energieminister Tagen im krisenmodus
in einem sind sich alle einig man dürfe
mit Blick auf die Energiepreise keine
Zeit mehr verlieren wir befinden uns in
einem energiekrieg mit Russland wir
werden alles tun was nötig ist um unsere
Wirtschaft zu schützen und
sicherzustellen dass wir genug Energie
zu bezahlbaren Preisen haben
eine Idee um das zu erreichen ist den
Strommarkt umzugestalten bisher wird der
Strompreis in Europa vor allem vom
teuren Gas bestimmt die Produktion von
Strom aus erneuerbaren Energiequellen
oder auch aus Atomkraft ist wesentlich
günstiger der Verkaufspreis richtet sich
aber nach dem teuren Strom so entstehen
derzeit bei einigen Stromproduzenten
ungewöhnlich hohe Gewinne künftig könnte
der Preis gestaffelt nach Energiequelle
gebremst und somit vom Gas entkoppelt
werden wir machen hier etwas was das
Herz der europäischen Energieversorgung
betrifft nämlich wir greifen in die
Märkte ein ein System das sich über
Jahre Jahrzehnte aufgebaut hat wird es
in wenigen Wochen oder Monaten verändert
so sind die Zeiten man darf sich davor
nicht drücken aber natürlich müssen wir
sehr genau wissen was wir dort tun es
ist nun Aufgabe der EU-Kommission alle
Vorschläge technisch auszuarbeiten
möglichst schon nächste Woche unmöglich
so dass eine Mehrheit der
Mitgliedstaaten zustimmen kann eine
Mehrheit für einen preisdeckel auf
russisches Gas zeichnete sich heute
nicht ab
die Energiepreise Treiben in Deutschland
viele um die Bundesregierung versucht
mit einem dritten Paket die Menschen zu
entlasten wir haben dazu einen aktuelles
Politbarometer und die Ergebnisse die
hat Matthias frauenhoff guten Abend
Matthias hallo guten Abend wie kommen
die Maßnahmen an der Eindruck ist
jedenfalls dass die Bundesregierung zu
wenig tut um die Bürger zu entlasten das
Sagen 49 Prozent der Befragten
insbesondere Menschen mit geringem
Einkommen müssten mehr Unterstützung
erhalten das finden sogar 68%
Energiesicherheit ist ein großes Thema
geworden und da sehen wir ein klares
Bild auch was Atomkraftwerke betrifft
nur zwölf Prozent wollen sie zum
Jahresende komplett vom Netz nehmen 32%
finden es richtig sie als Notreserve bis
April zu erhalten und eine Mehrheit von
54 Prozent sagt die verbliebenen AKW
sollten länger betrieben werden und wie
schneiden die Parteien gerade ab da gibt
es tatsächlich einiges an Bewegung denn
wenn am Sonntag Bundestagswahl wäre käme
die SPD wie im August auf 19 Prozent die
Union stärkste Kraft 28 + 2 die Grünen
verlieren kräftig 23 - 3
fdp6-1 AFD 13 linke 5% beide plus 1
die Ampel hätte damit weiter eine wenn
auch geschrumpfte Mehrheit danke für die
Zahlen Matthias
und das gesamte Politbarometer können
Sie an diesem Abend im heute-journal
sehen
mit einem Frontalangriff auf die
Regierung hat die CDU ihren partei-tag
in Hannover eröffnet es ist das erste
Delegiertentreffen unter der neuen
Führung von Friedrich Merz der
bezeichnete die Ampel als eine der
schwächsten Regierungen aller Zeiten um
ein Gegenkonzept zu haben will die CDU
entlastungsvorschläge Arbeiten weiteres
wichtiges Thema die Einführung einer
Frauenquote Streit ist programmiert
Matthies Feldhoff
endlich mal klare Kante so kann man den
Applaus nach gut einer Stunde
Standortbestimmung durch den Parteichef
wohl interpretieren Friedrich Merz teilt
aus gegen den Kanzler gegen den
Wirtschaftsminister es ist die Rede
eines Oppositionsführers der sich mit
seiner Partei auf Augenhöhe mit der
Regierung sieht wir sind die viertgrößte
Industrienation der Welt die sich nicht
leisten kann ein Traineeprogramm für
Bundeswirtschaftsminister aufzusetzen
sondern wir brauchen hier Menschen in
den Ämtern die was verstehen von der
Aufgabe die sie da wahrnehmen ich
fordere von dieser Stelle den
Bundeskanzler auf stoppen Sie dieses
rot-grün-gelbe Narrenschiff Friedrich
Merz legt den Finger in die Wunden der
Koalition er hätte marderpanzer nach
Kiew geliefert er würde nicht zögern bei
der Nutzung der Atomenergie in einem
Leitantrag formuliert die Union ihre
Alternativen etwa einen gaspreisdeckel
statt der gasumlage umstritten der
Vorschlag eine Frauenquote einzuführen
in zwei Schritten auf 50% bisher sind
Frauen in der CDU unterrepräsentiert wir
versuchen es ja seit über 40 Jahren mit
anderen bessere Rahmenbedingungen für
Frauen all das hat ja nicht den Erfolg
gebracht den wir uns wünschen wenn ich
bin gegen die Quote denn sie bekämpft
vielmehr die Symptome und nicht die
Ursachen warum wir zu wenig Frauen in
der Politik haben die Lager der Gegner
und Befürworter der Quote sind etwa
gleich groß doch den offenen Streit den
Riss durch die Partei will die CDU heute
vermeiden abgestimmt wird noch am Abend
sind und bleiben Russland muss bei
seinem Angriffskrieg Rückschläge
verkraften im russischen Staatsfernsehen
hieß es der ukrainischen Armee gelangen
im Rahmen einer Gegenoffensive Vorstöße
rund um die Stadt rakev der ukrainische
Präsident selensky Sprachen Kiew von
dutzenden Siedlungen die befreit worden
sein die russische Armee veröffentlichte
diese Bilder zu sehen sein sollen
Militärfahrzeuge die Nachschub für die
russischen Truppen in die Region
im bayerischen Ansbach hat gestern Abend
ein messerangreifer zwei Passanten
verletzt und es daraufhin von Polizisten
erschossen worden Hinweise auf ein
islamistisches oder terroristisches
Motiv bestätigen sich zunächst nicht so
die Ermittler heute der mutmaßliche
Täter 31-jähriger abgelehnter
Asylbewerber hatte bei seiner Attacke
laut Zeugen aller Aqua Gottes groß
gerufen
bei uns ist die große Sommerhitze ja
vorbei Kalifornien sitzt dagegen unter
einer regelrechten Hitze Glocke von
teils mehr als 40 Grad an mehreren
Stellen sind Waldbrände ausgebrochen
rund um Los Angeles und vor allem im
Norden des US-Bundesstaates in der
Region placer County in den Bergen der
Sierra Nevada sind mehr als 3000 Häuser
von den Flammen bedroht Regen ist
vielerorts nicht in Sicht
da kommen wir jetzt zum Fußball Norbert
und zu den schlimmen Szenen gestern
Abend der Nizza allerdings heftige
Ausschreitungen im Stadion 32 verletzte
vor dem conference League Spiel der
Kölner in Südfrankreich die Partie
konnte erst knapp eine Stunde später
angepfiffen werden offensichtlich sind
vor allem deutsche Chaoten für die
Randale verantwortlich
es sind schreckliche Szenen der Gewalt
Aggressionen gegen die Fans von Nizza
die wiederum gegen Gewalt erzeugen
friedliche Kölner Fans Filmen die
Attacken und werden selber angegriffen
wir haben ja 8000 Menschen aus Köln
dabei davon über 7.900 die sich hier top
Verhalten von Nizza sind es glaube ich
auch nicht viel mehr wie ein paar
Dutzend voll Chaoten fünf Auswärtsspiele
des FC in europäischen Wettbewerben
binnen 30 Jahren dreimal kam es zur
Ausschreitungen durch Kölner Hooligans
der Club muss mit Strafen rechnen
das sportliche Gerät in den Hintergrund
dem 1:0 für Köln durch Tigges in der 19
Minute folgt in der 62 der Ausgleich
durch the Love nach Hand Elfmeter ein
schwerverletzter Hooligan der aus dem
Oberrang stürzte soll inzwischen außer
Lebensgefahr sein
zur
basketball-heim EM nach dem Mitreisenden
vorrundenauftritt des deutschen Team
startet ja jetzt in Berlin die Ko-Runde
im Achtelfinale trifft das Team morgen
auf Montenegro wie sagt man doch so
schön ein machbarer Gegner
aber auch der muss erst einmal bezwungen
werden auf dem Weg für Deutschland zu
möglichen dritten EM-Medaille
wissen Sie wir tun drei Dinge wir werden
hart spielen wir werden zusammen spielen
und wir werden die Situation genießen
das haben wir vom ersten Tag an gesagt
zurück im Team die NBA-Profis Schröder
und Theiss gegen Ungarn noch geschont
unser Ziel ist es eine Medaille zu
gewinnen und wir werden alle werden
nicht jünger die Mischung aus jung und
alt ist gefragt denn nun kann jedes
Spiel das vorzeitige Aus bedeuten
wir waren erst in der Todesgruppe jetzt
sind wir in der Todes KO-Phase bezüngt
Deutschland Außenseiter Montenegro
wartet ein Turnierfavorit Griechenland
im Viertelfinale
und das war es auch schon vom Sport
Dankeschön und wir kommen noch mal zur
Rede von König Charles dem dritten er
gab bekannt dass sein Sohn William neuer
Prinz of Wales wird und das London haben
wir noch diese aktuellen Bilder gerade
jetzt findet ein Gedenkgottesdienst
statt in das St Pauls geceiver eine der
größten Kirchen der Welt doch genug
Platz für alle die an der Andacht für
die Queen teilnehmen wollten bietet auch
sie nicht
ein bewegender Moment reserviert für die
Einwohnerinnen und Einwohner Londons
keine Royale Familie kaum VIP sind hier
dabei eine Stadt verabschiedet sich von
Elisabeth II
und noch ein kurzer Blick aufs Wetter
morgen geht es unbeständig weiter die
Details hat gleich Christoph für Sie das
heute journal können Sie um 22 Uhr sehen
mit Marietta Slomka und jetzt geht es
hier weiter mit dem zdf-spezial
[Musik]
guten Abend in Nordeuropa haben wir
morgen 10 15 am Mittelmeer 30-35 Grad
und wir liegen genau dazwischen eben nur
mäßig warmen Bereich denn tief Peggy
überquert uns langsam mit unbeständigen
und windigen Wetter aber in der neuen
Woche schaufelt dann Ex Hurrican Daniel
doch noch mal die warme Mittelmeerluft
zu uns aber zuerst wie gesagt zum
relativ kühlen Wochenende mit nur 14 bis
8 Grad morgen früh dazu ziehen die
shower und Gewitter heute Nacht Richtung
Nordosten aus dem Südwesten kommt in der
zweiten Nachthälfte aber dann noch mal
neuer Regen auf und der breitet sich am
Vormittag in den Westen und den Süden
aus im Norden und Osten gibt es viele
freundliche Abschnitte doch nachmittags
sind dann noch hier viele kurze schaue
und Gewitter unterwegs vor allem im
Westen und der Mitte haben wir auch noch
diesen gewittrigen Regen bei einem
auflebenden Westwind hier auch nur 0 bis
2 Stunden Sonne im Osten kommt immerhin
sieben Stunden Sonne deswegen gibt es
auch hier bis zu 21 Grad ansonsten
bleiben wir teils deutlich unter 20 Grad
mit nur 15 Grad am Alpenrand am Sonntag
hängen die Reste dieser shower Gewitter
noch im Südosten von Westen her wird es
aber schon wieder trockener und in der
neuen Woche erreicht die Temperaturen im
Südwesten bis 28 Grad tschüss